bienvenue dans cette série sur la compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantiques, je m'appelle John Watrous et je suis directeur technique de l'éducation chez IBM
Quantum. C'est la 10e leçon de la série et la deuxième leçon de la troisième unité, qui porte sur la formulation générale
de l'information quantique. Cette leçon traite des canaux, qui représentent des changements dans les
systèmes qui stockent de l'information quantique. Cela inclut des opérations utiles comme celles effectuées par
des gates unitaires et des circuits quantiques, ainsi que des changements que l'on préférerait éviter, comme le bruit. On peut aussi décrire les mesures
comme des canaux, et c'est quelque chose qu'on abordera dans la prochaine leçon. Le terme canal nous vient de la
théorie de l'information, qui étudie entre autres la capacité de transmission de l'information des communications bruyantes
canaux. Donc quand on pense aux canaux, on pense de manière abstraite aux canaux de communication.
Ça peut sembler un peu étrange de penser à un calcul complexe comme à un canal de communication, mais on a besoin d'un
mot pour désigner la notion générale d'un processus qui modifie l'information d'une façon ou d'une autre, et pour le meilleur ou pour le pire, le mot
canal s'est imposé, sans doute en grande partie grâce à l'énorme impact que la théorie de l'information, et en particulier les
travaux de Claude Shannon dans les années 1940, a eu sur l'information et le calcul quantiques. Voici un aperçu de la
leçon. On commencera par les bases, notamment la définition de ce qu'est un canal, ainsi que la façon dont les opérations unitaires dans la formulation simplifiée
de l'information quantique peuvent être décrites comme des canaux. On parlera aussi du fait que les combinaisons convexes de canaux sont des canaux, et si tu te demandes
pourquoi cette notion de convexité revient sans cesse, c'est parce qu'elle est vraiment une notion mathématique fondamentalement importante dans la théorie de
l'information quantique. On verra aussi quelques exemples de canaux, notamment des canaux à qubit, qui réapparaîtront de temps
en temps dans la suite de la leçon. Dans la deuxième partie de la leçon, on parlera de trois façons différentes de représenter les canaux
mathématiquement, et en particulier des représentations de Stinespring, des représentations de Krauss et de Choi
qui portent le nom de trois personnes dont les travaux ont été importants dans le développement de ces différentes représentations. Dans la troisième et
dernière partie de la leçon, on discutera d'une preuve mathématique qui établit que ces trois représentations sont en fait équivalentes, ainsi que le fait qu'elles
caractérisent toutes correctement la définition de ce qu'est un canal. C'est une preuve mathématique vraiment cool à mon avis, et j'espère qu'elle apportera un peu de
clarté sur ces différentes présentations, comment elles se rapportent et comment elles fonctionnent en général. On commencera par les bases et
on abordera la question : que sont les canaux ? Comme je l'ai déjà suggéré au début de la leçon, les canaux décrivent des changements,
plus précisément des changements en temps discret dans les systèmes qui stockent de l'information quantique. Ici, quand on parle d'un changement en temps discret,
on pense simplement à un changement qui se produit entre deux moments distincts dans le temps, par opposition à un
processus continu, par exemple, qui a du sens à envisager sur des périodes de temps infiniment petites. Les canaux incluent des opérations utiles comme
les opérations unitaires effectuées par des Quantum Gates et des circuits, ainsi que des changements dus au bruit. Par exemple, pour
les besoins de cette leçon, on va principalement penser aux canaux en termes mathématiques abstraits, et il n'y aura pas de besoin particulier
de distinguer ce qui est utile de ce qui ne l'est pas. Les noms typiques des canaux incluent les lettres grecques majuscules phi,
psi et delta, et on utilisera des lettres différentes pour désigner certains canaux spécifiques. Dans une situation simple où
on a un système dans un état décrit par une matrice densité rho, et qu'on applique un canal fi à ce système,
le résultat est un système dont l'état est décrit par la matrice densité fi de rho. Donc on pense à un
canal fi donné comme étant une fonction qui peut être appliquée aux matrices densité d'une taille particulière, ou en d'autres termes
aux matrices densité d'un système particulier auquel on applique ce canal. Il y a quelques exigences que les canaux doivent satisfaire pour être
considérés comme des canaux valides. Premièrement, les canaux sont des applications linéaires. C'est complètement analogue à la situation qu'on a
dans la formulation simplifiée de l'information quantique, où les opérations sur les vecteurs d'état quantiques sont nécessairement linéaires,
tout comme dans la formulation standard de l'information classique où les opérations probabilistes sont linéaires. Tu pourrais choisir de remettre en question cette
exigence de base de linéarité si tu le souhaitais vraiment, mais si on veut une théorie cohérente à la fois avec la théorie des probabilités
et le choix de représenter les états quantiques par des matrices densité, alors on n'a pas vraiment le choix et on doit simplement accepter que les canaux sont linéaires.
La deuxième exigence est que les canaux transforment les matrices densité en matrices densité. C'est tout à fait logique, car si on a choisi de représenter
les états des systèmes par des matrices densité et qu'on applique un canal à un système dans un certain état, alors le résultat doit être un état valide et donc
représenté par une matrice densité. Il y a cependant un point très important à ajouter ici, à savoir que cette exigence
doit être vraie non seulement si on applique un canal à un système isolé dont l'état est décrit par une matrice densité,
mais aussi si on a un système composé dont l'état est décrit par une matrice densité et qu'on applique le canal à seulement
une partie de ce système. Ce sont donc les exigences qu'on impose aux canaux, et on peut voir qu'elles sont très
analogues aux exigences qu'on a pour les opérations dans la formulation simplifiée de l'information quantique et dans la formulation standard
de l'information classique. Dans la formulation simplifiée de l'information quantique, les opérations sont représentées par des matrices unitaires parce qu'elles
correspondent précisément aux applications linéaires qui transforment toujours les vecteurs d'état quantiques en vecteurs d'état quantiques pour un
système donné, et de même, les opérations probabilistes sont représentées par des matrices stochastiques parce que ce sont celles qui
transforment toujours les vecteurs de probabilité en vecteurs de probabilité. Ici on travaille avec des matrices densité et il y a
cette exigence supplémentaire concernant les systèmes composés, qui s'avère ne pas être nécessaire pour les vecteurs d'état quantiques
ni pour les vecteurs de probabilité, mais sinon les exigences sont analogues et dans un certain sens nous sont imposées par le choix
de représenter les états quantiques par des matrices densité. Voici quelques détails supplémentaires sur les canaux, notamment une convention
sur la façon dont on va penser aux systèmes d'entrée et de sortie d'un canal tout au long de la leçon, ainsi que quelques détails supplémentaires
sur l'exigence que les canaux transforment toujours les matrices densité en matrices densité. Premièrement, chaque canal est
supposé avoir un système d'entrée et un système de sortie. On peut nommer ces systèmes comme on le souhaite, mais tout au long de cette
leçon, je vais utiliser le nom X pour désigner le système d'entrée et le nom Y pour désigner le système de sortie. Conceptuellement, le canal
transforme le système d'entrée en système de sortie. Donc les systèmes d'entrée et de sortie ne coexistent jamais simultanément.
On commence avec X, le canal est appliqué ou exécuté, et le résultat est que X a été transformé en Y dont l'état est
déterminé par l'application linéaire associée au canal. Les systèmes d'entrée et de sortie d'un canal n'ont pas besoin d'être identiques, et en particulier
ils n'ont pas besoin d'avoir le même nombre d'états classiques. Cependant, il peut arriver que les systèmes d'entrée et de sortie soient en fait le même système, ou en d'autres
WEBVTT
termes x est égal à y, auquel cas on imagine simplement que fi change l'état du système, et c'est d'ailleurs
très souvent la situation qui nous intéresse, mais cette possibilité est cohérente avec le premier point dans le sens où on n'a jamais
les systèmes d'entrée et de sortie existant comme deux systèmes séparés en même temps. Dans tous les cas, ça va être pratique pour
les besoins de cette leçon d'utiliser des lettres différentes, à savoir X et Y, pour désigner les systèmes d'entrée et de sortie,
juste pour nous aider à garder les choses claires. Maintenant entrons un peu plus dans les détails sur l'exigence que les canaux transforment toujours les matrices densité
en matrices densité. Supposons qu'on introduise un nouveau système Z dans l'image.
Donnons le nom gamma à l'ensemble d'états classiques de ce nouveau système. Imagine maintenant qu'on forme un nouveau système composé ZX
constitué du nouveau système avec le système d'entrée X d'un canal fi, et supposons que ce système composé est
dans un état décrit par une matrice densité rho. Il peut s'agir d'un état quantique arbitraire de cette paire, mais quel que soit l'état,
il est toujours possible d'exprimer la matrice densité Rho sous la forme montrée à l'écran, où A et B
parcourent tous les deux l'ensemble d'états classiques gamma, et chaque rho AB est une matrice dont les lignes et colonnes correspondent à quel que soit
l'ensemble d'états classiques de X. Et on n'a pas besoin de donner un nom à cet ensemble d'états classiques à ce stade. Pour être clair, chaque rho AB n'est pas nécessairement une
matrice densité en soi, mais la matrice entière rho est nécessairement une matrice densité. Quand on applique le canal fi au
système X, il est transformé en Y et on se retrouve avec la paire ZY. La façon dont on détermine
l'état de cette paire après avoir appliqué fi sur juste X est d'évaluer l'application linéaire fi sur chacune des matrices rho A.
Une autre façon de dire ça est qu'on prend le produit tensoriel de l'application fi avec l'application identité sur les matrices carrées ayant des lignes et colonnes
correspondant à gamma, ce qui correspond à ne rien faire à ce nouveau système Z. Mais c'est une description équivalente
et elle n'oblige pas à entrer dans les détails sur les produits tensoriels d'applications de cette forme. Ils
fonctionnent cependant de manière assez directe, analogue à la façon dont ils fonctionnent pour les vecteurs et les matrices. Une façon de visualiser ça
est en termes de matrices par blocs et si on fait l'hypothèse simplificatrice que l'ensemble d'états classiques gamma consiste en
les entiers entre 0 et N moins un pour un certain entier positif M, alors il devient facile d'écrire tout ça comme c'est
montré ici. Et maintenant pour réitérer l'exigence qu'on impose à fi pour qu'il soit un canal valide, on doit toujours obtenir une matrice densité
de ce processus, et ça doit être vrai quel que soit le choix qu'on fait pour le système Z ainsi que le
choix qu'on fait pour rho, pourvu que ce soit une matrice densité. Ça peut sembler une exigence assez stricte et
il peut aussi sembler très difficile à vérifier, mais comme on le verra à la fin de la leçon, ce n'est en fait pas si strict
ni difficile à vérifier, et en particulier on a de belles caractérisations mathématiques pour cette condition
qui sont liées aux différentes représentations dont on parlera un peu plus tard dans la leçon. Voyons maintenant quelques exemples de canaux,
en commençant par toute une catégorie de canaux appelés canaux unitaires. En termes simples, ce sont des
opérations unitaires, tout comme on en a dans la formulation simplifiée de l'information quantique, vues comme des canaux. Pour être précis, supposons que U est une
matrice unitaire qui représente une opération unitaire sur un système X. Donc dans la formulation simplifiée de l'information
quantique, on multiplierait cette matrice par un vecteur d'état quantique donné pour déterminer l'action que cette opération a sur cet état quantique.
La façon dont ça fonctionne pour les matrices densité est qu'on multiplie la matrice densité à gauche par U et à droite par U
dagger. En termes mathématiques, on appelle cette opération la conjugaison par la matrice U. C'est cohérent avec
|psi><psi| étant la matrice densité qui décrit l'état représenté par le vecteur d'état quantique |psi>, et c'est assez
facile de vérifier qu'en particulier si on appliquait U au vecteur d'état quantique |ki>, on obtiendrait U * |ki>, et sa
représentation en matrice densité est donnée par ce vecteur multiplié par sa transposée conjuguée, soit U * |ki> * <psi| * U
dagger quand on évalue la transposée conjuguée de U * |ki>. Donc la façon dont ce canal est défini
a du sens pour les états purs, et quand on combine ça avec la linéarité, on voit que ça a du sens pour les matrices densité en
général, grâce au fait que chaque matrice densité peut être exprimée comme une combinaison convexe d'états purs. Cette
définition nous donne toujours un canal valide pour tout choix d'opération unitaire u. En particulier, la conjugaison par
une matrice unitaire comme ça ne change pas la trace d'une matrice, et si on conjugue une matrice semi-définie positive
par n'importe quelle matrice, on obtiendra une autre matrice semi-définie positive, et c'est assez facile d'obtenir ça
directement à partir de la définition des matrices semi-définies positives. Donc les matrices densité sont toujours transformées en matrices densité
et tout ça reste vrai même si on tensorise U avec la matrice identité de n'importe quelle taille, ce qui est équivalent
à appliquer ce canal à seulement une partie d'un système composé. Voici un exemple très simple d'un canal unitaire. Supposons qu'on
prenne U comme étant la matrice identité. C'est très clairement un canal valide appelé le canal identité. Ne
rien faire est certainement une opération linéaire et si on commence avec une matrice densité et qu'on ne fait rien, elle
sera toujours une matrice densité. Donc c'est un canal valide. Les gens utilisent différents symboles pour désigner ce canal,
parfois c'est exactement le même symbole qu'on utilise pour la matrice identité, ce qui peut être un peu déroutant, mais en général ça ne l'est pas. Ici j'utilise les
lettres ID, abréviation d'identité, juste pour éviter toute confusion, et cette notation est aussi assez courante. Ça peut sembler être un
canal très ennuyeux, mais dans le contexte de la transmission de l'information, c'est en fait un canal parfait où le
récepteur reçoit exactement ce que l'expéditeur envoie, ce qui est typiquement ce qu'on veut dans ce contexte. Une autre façon d'obtenir
plein d'exemples de canaux est de prendre des combinaisons convexes de canaux, ou en d'autres termes de les moyenner
ensemble. Et le fait qu'on puisse faire ça est un aspect important des canaux. Pour l'expliquer plus en détail, commençons avec deux canaux F0 et F1,
avec un nombre réel P entre 0 et 1. Et pour être clair, on suppose que ces deux canaux ont
le même système d'entrée X ainsi que le même système de sortie Y. Considère maintenant ce qui se passe si on décide
d'appliquer le premier canal F0 avec probabilité p, et sinon avec la probabilité restante 1 moins P on applique
le deuxième canal F1. Par exemple, peut-être qu'on choisit aléatoirement un bit avec ces probabilités, et qu'on utilise ce bit aléatoire
pour déterminer quel canal appliquer. En faisant ça, on applique effectivement un nouveau canal qu'on pourrait appeler psi,
donné par une combinaison convexe des deux canaux avec lesquels on a commencé, et qu'on peut exprimer comme c'est écrit
à l'écran. On peut toujours prendre des combinaisons linéaires d'applications linéaires comme ça d'ailleurs, et la façon dont une combinaison linéaire
d'applications linéaires est définie sur une entrée donnée, c'est qu'on prend simplement la même combinaison linéaire des sorties.
Ça peut sembler un peu trivial mais ça a du sens. La sortie qu'on obtient de ce scénario hypothétique est simplement la
moyenne pondérée des sorties qu'on obtiendrait des deux canaux d'origine. Néanmoins, c'est un nouveau canal et
si fi0 et fi1 étaient bien des canaux valides, alors bien sûr cette nouvelle application sera aussi un canal valide. Une autre façon de dire
ça en termes mathématiques est que l'ensemble de tous les canaux d'un système d'entrée donné vers un système de sortie donné est
convexe, et c'est une propriété mathématique importante des canaux. On peut le faire plus généralement si on a M canaux fi0 à fi m moins un,
avec le vecteur de probabilité qui nous dit quelle est la probabilité pour chaque canal, alors on obtient un nouveau canal en moyennant les canaux en conséquence. Donc
dans un sens, c'est une source inépuisable de nouveaux canaux. Par exemple, la classe des canaux dits unitaires mixtes est ce qu'on
obtient en prenant des combinaisons convexes de canaux unitaires. C'est-à-dire que si on a M matrices unitaires u0 à u m moins
un, toutes de même taille, avec le vecteur de probabilité, et qu'on prend la moyenne pondérée des canaux
correspondant aux matrices unitaires individuelles comme c'est montré ici à l'écran, on obtiendra un canal. Et les canaux
qui peuvent être écrits ainsi sont appelés canaux unitaires mixtes. Tous les canaux ne sont pas des canaux unitaires mixtes ; on ne peut pas obtenir
tous les canaux de cette façon, mais ils apparaissent assez souvent. Ensuite, on va regarder quelques exemples spécifiques
de canaux. Ce seront tous des exemples de canaux d'un qubit vers un qubit, qu'on appelle canaux
à qubit pour faire court. Le premier s'appelle le canal de réinitialisation de qubit, et l'idée est que ce canal réinitialise un qubit
à l'état zéro. On utilise ici la lettre grecque majuscule Lambda pour désigner ce canal, et la façon de se souvenir de ce que ce canal fait est de
penser à la sphère de Bloch. La majuscule Lambda ressemble un peu à une flèche pointant vers le haut et l'état zéro est au sommet de la sphère de Bloch, donc c'est comme si
elle pointait vers l'emplacement de la sortie. La façon dont c'est défini en termes mathématiques est que Lambda de rho est égal à la trace de rho fois |0><0|. Donc
si on l'évalue sur n'importe quelle matrice densité rho, on obtiendra l'état zéro en tant que matrice densité. Il est naturel de se demander
pourquoi on a besoin de la trace. Ne pourrait-on pas simplement définir Lambda de rho comme étant |0><0| sans la trace de rho devant ?
Et la réponse à cette question est non. Les canaux doivent être des applications linéaires et ce ne serait pas linéaire si on retirait la trace de rho. Garde aussi à l'esprit que
parfois on a besoin de savoir comment un canal fonctionne comme application linéaire sur des entrées qui ne sont pas des matrices densité. Par exemple, comme on
l'a vu plus tôt, si on veut savoir ce que fait un canal quand on l'applique à un système composé, on a besoin
d'évaluer ce canal sur les blocs individuels d'une grande matrice par blocs, et bien que la grande matrice par blocs soit
une matrice densité, les blocs individuels ne le seront généralement pas. Voyons donc exactement ce que ce canal fait quand on l'applique
à juste une partie d'un système composé, et plus spécifiquement ce qu'il fait quand on l'applique à un des deux qubits qui
forment un ebit. Pour être précis, supposons que A et B sont des qubits qui en tant que paire sont dans l'état de Bell phi plus, et qu'on applique Lambda
au premier qubit A. Pour savoir ce qui se passe, exprimons d'abord l'état phi plus comme une matrice densité, et
pour les besoins de cet exemple, utilisons la notation de Dirac pour faire ça. Voici l'état phi plus comme un vecteur d'état quantique et voici ce qu'on obtient quand on
multiplie ce vecteur par sa transposée conjuguée et qu'on développe tout. On peut alors appliquer le canal au premier qubit et évaluer ce qu'on obtient. Voici
Lambda appliqué au premier qubit et voici ce qu'on obtient quand on évalue chacun des termes. La trace de |0><0| est 1
et la trace de |1><0|, et ça explique
les deux termes dans la réponse. La trace de |0><0|,
et donc ces deux termes s'évaluent à zéro et donc ne contribuent rien à la réponse. On peut maintenant simplifier un
peu et ce qu'on obtient c'est l'état zéro pour le premier qubit A et l'état complètement mixte pour
le deuxième qubit B. Remarque en particulier qu'on n'a pas obtenu un état plus pour B, ce qui n'aurait pas nécessairement
été une mauvaise hypothèse si on ne savait rien des matrices densité et qu'on regardait juste la représentation en vecteur d'état quantique de l'état. Mais c'est
pas comme ça que ce canal fonctionne, et il n'existe aucun canal qui pourrait fonctionner ainsi. Le canal Lambda est appelé le canal de réinitialisation de qubit, mais
la façon dont il fonctionne ressemble vraiment plus à jeter le qubit d'entrée à la poubelle et à le remplacer par un qubit neuf dans l'état zéro. Mais c'est en fait
le seul canal à qubit qui génère toujours l'état zéro. Voici un autre exemple de canal à qubit, connu sous le nom de
canal complètement déphasant. Celui-ci est désigné par Delta et la façon dont il fonctionne est qu'il laisse les entrées diagonales
de toute matrice 2x2 intactes et met à zéro les entrées hors diagonale. Delta est la lettre grecque équivalente au D dans
l'alphabet latin, et c'est l'abréviation de diagonal. C'est donc une façon de se souvenir de ce que ce canal fait. On peut
alternativement exprimer ce canal en notation de Dirac comme c'est montré à l'écran. Et pour être clair, la sortie
est toujours une matrice 2x2. Donc en particulier, les deux sorties zéro désignent la matrice 2x2 entièrement nulle. On fait souvent
ça et on l'a vu avant dans cette série. Le symbole zéro est généralement utilisé, peut-être de manière ambiguë, pour signifier l'élément zéro
de n'importe quelle chose dont on parle, que ce soient des scalaires, des vecteurs, des matrices ou autre. Faisons la même chose qu'on a faite précédemment pour
le canal de réinitialisation de qubit et voyons ce qui se passe si on applique ce canal à la moitié d'un ebit. La configuration est la même, donc je ne vais pas
répéter cette partie. Le résultat est l'état montré à l'écran, qui est essentiellement un bit aléatoire partagé. Donc
ce que ce canal a fait, c'est essentiellement convertir un ebit en une paire parfaitement corrélée de bits aléatoires classiques
et c'est cohérent avec une interprétation plus générale de ce canal. En mettant à zéro les entrées hors diagonale d'une matrice densité, on
jette effectivement le côté quantique d'une matrice densité, laissant une matrice densité diagonale qui représente un
état probabiliste classique. Une autre façon de penser à ça est que ce canal représente un canal classique parfait et sans bruit qui transmet un bit.
Donc si on met un état zéro ou un état un, ou une combinaison convexe de ces deux états dans le canal, alors cet état sort inchangé. Mais si tu essaies de
mettre un état quantique, comme un état plus par exemple, c'est comme si le canal mesurait cet état avec une mesure en base standard et puis
transmettait le résultat classique. Un dernier exemple de canal à qubit est le canal complètement dépolarisant.
Ce que fait ce canal, c'est de toujours produire l'état complètement mixte. Donc c'est similaire dans un sens au canal de réinitialisation de qubit
sauf qu'on obtient un état complètement mixte plutôt peu utile au lieu d'un qubit initialisé. Une façon naturelle
de penser à ce canal est qu'il représente une forme extrême de bruit, et en ce qui concerne les canaux à qubit,
ça ne peut vraiment pas être plus bruyant que ça. Je n'ai pas de bon moyen mnémotechnique à partager pour se souvenir de ce que celui-là fait, si ce n'est que Omega est la dernière
lettre de l'alphabet grec et elle est parfois associée à la fin de toutes choses, et c'est peut-être ce qui se passe
WEBVTT
à tous les qubits éventuellement. En ce qui concerne le bruit, c'est assez extrême, mais une chose qu'on peut faire est de considérer une combinaison convexe
de ce canal et du canal identité avec peut-être une petite probabilité epsilon pour la
dépolarisation complète. C'est une forme de bruit moins extrême où un état de qubit donné sera principalement laissé intact, mais il y a
une petite chance qu'il devienne complètement mixte. Géométriquement, on peut penser à ça comme une légère contraction de la sphère de Bloch vers le centre.
Et soit dit en passant, on peut faire quelque chose de similaire avec le canal complètement déphasant pour modéliser le processus de décohérence par exemple, où les choses
deviennent légèrement plus classiques par un certain processus. Voilà donc trois exemples basiques de canaux à qubit, et on
va y revenir principalement comme source d'exemples tout au long du reste de la leçon. Ensuite, on va discuter des représentations
mathématiques des canaux, en commençant par une question de base. Les applications linéaires de vecteurs à vecteurs peuvent toujours être
représentées par des matrices de manière familière, c'est-à-dire que l'action de l'application linéaire est décrite par la
multiplication matrice-vecteur. Mais les canaux sont des applications linéaires de matrices à matrices, pas de vecteurs à vecteurs. Donc
en général, comment peut-on exprimer les canaux en termes mathématiques ? Parfois, pour des canaux spéciaux, on aura une formule simple
qui les décrit, et c'était le cas dans les exemples de canaux à qubit qu'on a déjà discutés. Mais ce n'est
pas pratique en général car il n'y aura pas toujours une formule aussi élégante. À titre de comparaison, dans la formulation simplifiée
de l'information quantique, on utilise des matrices unitaires pour représenter les opérations sur les vecteurs d'état quantiques.
Chaque matrice unitaire représente une opération valide et chaque opération valide peut être exprimée comme une matrice unitaire. Donc
en essence, cette question demande comment faire ça pour les canaux. Et la réponse à cette question est qu'il y a en fait plusieurs façons de représenter
les canaux en termes mathématiques. En particulier, on va discuter de trois façons différentes de représenter les canaux qui portent
le nom de trois individus dont les travaux ont joué un rôle important dans leur développement : Stinespring, Krauss et Choi.
D'abord on va voir comment fonctionnent ces différentes représentations, puis dans la dernière partie de la leçon, on va voir comment les trois représentations se rapportent et en
particulier comment on peut convertir entre elles. On verra aussi que ces représentations capturent précisément les exigences qu'on a sur les canaux,
à savoir qu'ils sont des applications linéaires et qu'ils transforment toujours les matrices densité en matrices densité, même quand
ils sont appliqués à seulement une partie d'un système composé. En premier lieu, les représentations de Stinespring. Willam Forest Stinespring
était un mathématicien qui ne travaillait pas sur l'information quantique, et les représentations de Stinespring telles que je vais les décrire
ne sont dans un sens que le dérivé de ses travaux sur la théorie des opérateurs dans les années 1950. Mais ces travaux ont certainement
été une partie importante du développement des mathématiques sur lesquelles les canaux quantiques sont basés. L'idée derrière cette façon de représenter les canaux est que chaque
canal peut être implémenté d'une certaine façon que je vais maintenant décrire. D'abord on forme un système composé constitué de
l'entrée du canal qu'on implémente, avec un système de travail initialisé. Puis une
opération unitaire est effectuée sur le système composé. Et finalement, la partie du système composé résultant
qui correspond à la sortie du canal est laissée seule ou produite en sortie, et le reste est éliminé ou tracé. C'est utile d'exprimer
ça sous forme de diagramme, et c'est plus simple de commencer par le cas spécial où les systèmes d'entrée et de
sortie sont les mêmes. Ce diagramme d'ailleurs ressemble exactement à un diagramme de circuit quantique, sauf que les fils
représentent des systèmes arbitraires et pas nécessairement des qubits individuels. Donc on commence avec le système d'entrée X dans un certain
état rho. On introduit un système de travail initialisé W et dans ce diagramme je suppose que zéro est un état classique
de W et on prend |0> comme état initialisé du système. Mais on pourrait alternativement fixer n'importe quel état pur
de W et le considérer comme l'état initialisé. On effectue ensuite une opération unitaire sur la paire WX, et puis on
trace le système de travail et on produit X en sortie. Dans le diagramme d'ailleurs, j'utilise le symbole de masse de
l'électrotechnique pour indiquer que W est éliminé. Ce n'est pas nécessairement conventionnel et tu ne trouveras
pas ce symbole dans Qiskit. Là-dedans, tu ignores juste les qubits qui ne t'intéressent pas. Le but est que je veux juste avoir un symbole qui indique clairement
qu'on élimine le système pour les besoins de cette discussion. En général, on n'a pas nécessairement besoin que
les systèmes d'entrée et de sortie soient les mêmes. On peut donc avoir par exemple un système de sortie Y ainsi qu'un
système poubelle G qui est tracé. Pour que U soit unitaire, il doit être une matrice carrée, donc il y a une hypothèse
que la paire GY ensemble a le même nombre d'états classiques que la paire WX. Par exemple, peut-être que ces systèmes
sont constitués de qubits et que le système d'entrée X est constitué de 5 qubits et W de 10 qubits. Donc U est une opération unitaire
sur 15 qubits. Il pourrait alors arriver que Y soit constitué de seulement 4 qubits, ce qui signifie que G est constitué de 11 qubits.
Ou peut-être que ce ne sont pas du tout des qubits. Tout ce qui est important c'est que WX ensemble et GY ensemble aient le même nombre
d'états classiques pour que U puisse être unitaire. Une description d'un canal comme ça est appelée une représentation de Stinespring du canal. Il est maintenant
assez simple de montrer que toute application fi qui peut être décrite de cette façon est en fait un canal valide.
En particulier, si on commence avec la matrice densité et qu'on ajoute un système de travail supplémentaire, on sera certainement
laissé avec une matrice densité. On a déjà observé qu'appliquer une opération unitaire nous donne un canal valide.
Et si on a une matrice densité d'un système composé et qu'on trace un des systèmes, on sera de nouveau laissé avec une matrice densité. Donc quand on compose
ces étapes, on sera garanti que ça transforme toujours les matrices densité en matrices densité. C'est aussi linéaire.
Ce qui n'est pas du tout clair à ce stade, c'est que chaque canal peut en effet être implémenté de cette façon pour un certain choix
du système de travail et du système poubelle, ainsi que de l'opération unitaire U bien sûr. Mais c'est vrai et on
verra pourquoi à la fin de la leçon. Voici un exemple de représentation de Stinespring pour le
canal à qubit complètement déphasant. Et pour être clair, les fils sont maintenant des qubits et c'est une CNOT ordinaire.
C'est très simple. Le qubit d'entrée est en haut et on a introduit un qubit de travail initialisé à l'état zéro.
On effectue ensuite une opération CNOT où le qubit d'entrée est le contrôle et le qubit de travail est la
cible, et puis le qubit de travail est tracé. Intuitivement, ça a du sens
que ça devrait implémenter le canal complètement déphasant, parce que la CNOT agit un peu comme une mesure en base standard sur le qubit du
haut en copiant son état classique sur le qubit du bas, et puis le résultat est jeté.
Mais on peut aussi faire un calcul et bien sûr c'est une bonne idée de faire ça parce qu'on ne devrait vraiment pas
WEBVTT
trop faire confiance à notre intuition. On peut commencer par écrire la représentation en matrice densité des
deux qubits après l'introduction du qubit de travail, et remarque qu'on utilise la convention d'ordonnancement des qubits
comme d'habitude, où le qubit du bas est celui de gauche et le qubit du haut est à droite. On peut exprimer cette matrice densité
explicitement comme une matrice 4x4 réelle comme c'est montré à l'écran, et puis on calcule l'effet
que la gate CNOT a sur cette matrice densité. On conjugue donc par la matrice unitaire associée à cette
gate, en gardant à nouveau à l'esprit la convention d'ordonnancement des qubits. Voici donc la matrice unitaire correcte
et le résultat est montré ici. En effet, la gate CNOT
a permuté les entrées de notre matrice d'origine un peu. Donc maintenant les entrées potentiellement non nulles sont dans les
quatre coins. Il reste à calculer la trace partielle et on pourrait le faire directement à partir de la matrice, mais une
alternative est de convertir en notation de Dirac comme c'est montré à l'écran, et alors il devient assez facile d'évaluer
ce qui se passe quand on trace le qubit de gauche dans chaque terme. Et le résultat est que seulement les
termes correspondant aux entrées diagonales de rho survivent, et on a donc déphasé le qubit comme
prévu. Comme toujours, vérifie ça par toi-même à ton propre rythme si tu choisis de le faire. C'est un bon
exemple pour s'entraîner à travailler avec les matrices densité et avec les traces
partielles. Ce n'est pas la seule façon d'implémenter le canal complètement déphasant. Voici une représentation de Stinespring alternative pour ce
canal. Je ne vais pas faire le calcul en détail dans cette vidéo, mais je vais le montrer brièvement au cas où tu aimerais mettre la vidéo en pause et regarder
de plus près. La façon dont ça fonctionne est similaire à la première, mais les détails sont
différents. Cette fois on commence avec une gate Hadamard sur le qubit de travail, ce qui le met dans un état plus. Et si
on développe le produit tensoriel, on obtient la matrice montrée à l'écran. Pour appliquer la gate Z contrôlée, on
conjugue par la matrice unitaire associée, et le résultat est d'injecter des signes moins dans la
matrice. En particulier, la dernière ligne et la dernière colonne sont toutes les deux multipliées par -1.
Et cette fois, il serait assez compliqué de convertir en notation de Dirac, donc on va calculer la trace partielle
directement. Quand on trace le premier des deux qubits, ce qu'on obtient c'est la somme des deux blocs diagonaux 2x2.
Et donc le résultat final est de nouveau qu'on a déphasé le qubit. C'était rapide, et si tu n'es pas
habitué à ces types de calculs, prends ton temps et fais-le lentement. La vitesse n'est pas importante
ici. Pour terminer cet exemple, mentionnons qu'il y a une idée assez simple derrière cette implémentation, qui est
assez bien exprimée par la dernière étape du calcul qu'on vient de parcourir en survol. Une façon plus succincte de le dire
est que si on fait la moyenne d'une matrice densité de qubit donnée avec cette matrice densité conjuguée par la matrice de Pauli Z, alors
c'est la même chose que de dephaser. Donc le canal complètement déphasant est aussi un canal unitaire mixte
où on ne fait soit rien, c'est-à-dire qu'on effectue l'opération identité, soit on effectue une gate Z, chacun
avec probabilité 1/2. Bon à savoir. Donc en résumé, on a deux représentations de Stinespring différentes
du canal complètement déphasant, et ça nous apprend quelque chose d'important, à savoir que les représentations de Stinespring ne sont
pas uniques, et en fait il en existe une infinité pour tout canal donné. Ensuite, on discute des représentations de Krauss
des canaux, qui nous offrent une façon formulaïque pratique d'exprimer les canaux par la
multiplication et l'addition de matrices. Les représentations de Krauss portent le nom de Karl Krauss, qui est un physicien qui entre autres
a travaillé sur beaucoup des détails mathématiques de base des canaux et de la formulation générale de l'information quantique plus largement. En général, une
représentation de Krauss est une expression d'un canal prenant la forme montrée ici à l'écran. En particulier, on a une
collection de matrices, nommées ici A0 à A n moins un pour un certain entier positif n, et elles spécifient
l'action du canal sur toute entrée donnée rho selon la formule. En bref, on conjugue rho par chacune de ces matrices
qui sont souvent appelées matrices de Krauss dans ce contexte, et puis on additionne le résultat, et ça nous donne la sortie. Toutes ces matrices doivent avoir
les mêmes dimensions et spécifiquement leurs colonnes doivent correspondre aux états classiques du système d'entrée et
les lignes doivent correspondre aux états classiques du système de sortie. Si c'est le cas, alors quand on prend le produit AK * rho * AK dagger pour tout
choix de K, on obtient une matrice carrée dont les lignes et colonnes correspondent aux états classiques du système de sortie,
et il est donc logique que l'expression produise une matrice densité du système de sortie. Or, il n'est pas vrai
que pour un choix arbitraire de ces matrices de Krauss on obtient un canal valide. Il existe cependant une condition assez simple
sur les matrices qui garantit qu'on obtiendra un canal valide, et cette condition est la formule affichée ici.
Plus précisément, si on additionne le produit de AK dagger * AK sur toutes les valeurs de K,
on doit obtenir la matrice identité, et ce sera la matrice identité dont les lignes et colonnes correspondent
aux états classiques du système d'entrée. Donc cette condition doit être satisfaite pour que l'application définie par la
première équation soit un canal valide. Et il s'avère que chaque canal a en fait une représentation qui prend
cette forme, du moment qu'on prend n suffisamment grand. Voici quelques exemples de représentations de Krauss,
en commençant par le canal de réinitialisation de qubit. On peut obtenir une représentation de Krauss pour ce canal en utilisant
deux matrices de Krauss : |0><1|. Donc n est égal à deux dans cet exemple.
On peut substituer ces choix dans la formule générale et on a juste deux termes, donc il est facile d'écrire la somme.
Et si on simplifie et qu'on reconnaît que l'expression entre parenthèses est la trace de rho, on voit qu'on obtient
le canal de réinitialisation de qubit. On peut aussi vérifier que la condition requise sur ces matrices est satisfaite, et c'est une simple question de substituer les matrices de Krauss
dans l'équation et d'évaluer, et on obtient la matrice identité comme requis. Pour un autre exemple, regardons de nouveau
le canal complètement déphasant. Prendre les matrices |0><1| fonctionne, et ça peut être vérifié en
développant la somme et en voyant assez directement qu'on obtient ce qu'on a besoin. Et de nouveau la condition requise est satisfaite. Une
alternative est de prendre A0 comme étant la matrice identité divisée par racine de 2 et A1 comme étant
Sigma Z divisé par racine de 2. Et si on évalue on voit qu'on obtient de nouveau le canal complètement déphasant, basé sur l'observation
WEBVTT
qu'on a faite sur ce canal un peu plus tôt dans la leçon. Et de nouveau, la condition requise est assez simple à
vérifier comme exercice à faire si tu trouves ça utile. Considère le canal complètement dépolarisant,
qui produit l'état complètement mixte pour chaque entrée de matrice densité. Pour celui-là, quatre matrices de Krauss
sont nécessaires. Il n'est pas possible de trouver une représentation de Krauss où n est trois ou moins. Voici un choix qui fonctionne et
en voici un autre. Donc l'exercice consiste à vérifier que ces choix fonctionnent ainsi qu'à vérifier que la condition requise
est satisfaite. Il vaut la peine de souligner que la deuxième alternative dit essentiellement qu'il est possible de dépolariser complètement un qubit, ou en d'autres termes de le
randomiser complètement, en choisissant aléatoirement une des quatre matrices de Pauli, y compris l'identité, et en appliquant
l'opération unitaire correspondante au qubit. Et donc le canal complètement dépolarisant est un autre exemple de canal
unitaire mixte. La dernière des trois représentations de canaux qu'on va couvrir est la représentation de Choi. Manduin Choi
est un mathématicien qui travaille sur la théorie des matrices et d'autres sujets, et la représentation de Choi porte son nom,
basée sur un article vraiment élégant qu'il a publié en 1975 qui dans un sens relie tout ça. La représentation de Choi
d'un canal fi est une matrice unique conventionnellement notée J(fi), et plus précisément si le
système d'entrée a n états classiques et le système de sortie en a M, alors la représentation de Choi de fi sera
une matrice carrée n * m par n * m. Avant de te dire exactement comment la matrice est définie, je voudrais mentionner deux
de ses propriétés clés qui motivent la représentation d'une façon que la définition elle-même peut ne pas avoir, du moins en
surface. Premièrement, à la différence des représentations de Stinespring et des représentations de Krauss, la représentation de Choi
est ce qu'on appelle une représentation fidèle, ce qui signifie que chaque canal en a une seule. Et c'est assez important
car ça dit que deux canaux sont les mêmes si et seulement si leurs représentations de Choi sont les mêmes. Donc si tu
as deux descriptions différentes de canaux, comme deux représentations de Stinespring différentes ou deux représentations de Krauss différentes, ou peut-être une de
chaque, et que tu veux savoir si ce sont en fait le même canal, tu peux juste calculer la représentation de Choi et
vérifier si elles sont égales ou non. La deuxième propriété est qu'il y a des conditions simples à vérifier sur la représentation de Choi qui sont vraies si et seulement
si on a un canal valide. Cette propriété n'est pas si spéciale ; on peut dire la même chose des deux autres représentations, mais c'est une bonne propriété
à avoir néanmoins, et on en discutera plus en détail bientôt. Une autre chose à noter sur la représentation de Choi est que bien qu'on
représente un canal par une matrice, cette matrice ne représente pas directement le canal comme une application linéaire. En fait,
il est plus naturel d'associer la représentation de Choi à la matrice densité qui représente un certain état
que de penser à la représentation de Choi comme décrivant une application linéaire. Il est cependant possible de récupérer l'action du canal à partir de
sa représentation de Choi en utilisant une formule assez simple, mais ce n'est pas aussi simple que la
multiplication matricielle ordinaire. C'est assez comme préambule. Passons à la définition réelle. Suppose qu'on a un canal fi d'un système X vers un système Y
et suppose que l'ensemble d'états classiques du système d'entrée X est Sigma. On n'a pas besoin de désigner l'ensemble d'états classiques du système de sortie donc
pour la définition il n'est pas nécessaire de le nommer. La représentation de Choi de fi est alors définie par l'expression
montrée ici à l'écran. On a une somme qui parcourt tous les états classiques A et B du système d'entrée, et on
additionne |a><b|. Donc cette
représentation est définie par une formule et il y a deux façons différentes d'y penser. Avant d'en parler cependant,
laisse-moi mentionner que parfois la représentation de Choi est définie d'une façon légèrement différente où l'ordre des deux facteurs tensoriels est inversé, ce qui signifie
que fi de |a><b| apparaît comme le premier facteur tensoriel plutôt que le deuxième. Mais les deux façons différentes de le faire sont
équivalentes à cette simple symétrie près. Mais ce que ça signifie c'est que quand tu utilises cette représentation, c'est une bonne
idée de préciser quel ordonnancement tu utilises. Cet ordonnancement est la façon dont c'est fait dans Qiskit et c'est aussi mieux pour
décrire la représentation visuellement en termes de matrices par blocs. Donc c'est celui qu'on va utiliser. Pour être plus précis sur la description en matrice par blocs,
si on suppose que l'ensemble d'états classiques Sigma consiste en les entiers de zéro jusqu'à n moins un
pour un certain entier positif n, alors on peut alternativement écrire J(fi) comme une matrice par blocs comme c'est montré ici à l'
écran. En d'autres termes, la représentation de Choi de fi est la matrice qu'on obtient en évaluant fi sur chacune des
matrices d'entrée qui ont exactement une entrée égale à 1 avec toutes leurs autres entrées nulles, et puis en les arrangeant
en une matrice de façon assez naturelle. Il n'est peut-être pas clair a priori pourquoi on voudrait former une telle matrice, mais il
s'avère que c'est très utile. Une chose à noter est que l'ensemble contenant les matrices |a><b| quand
A et B parcourent tous les entiers de 0 à n moins un forme une base pour l'espace de toutes les matrices n par n. Donc si
tu as cette matrice, tu peux certainement déterminer ce que fi fait à une matrice n par n arbitraire par linéarité,
spécifiquement en prenant des combinaisons linéaires appropriées des blocs. Donc la matrice J(fi) détermine en fait de façon unique
fi comme application linéaire. Une autre façon de penser à la représentation de Choi d'un canal est qu'elle
représente un état comme une matrice densité quand elle est normalisée, spécifiquement en la divisant par le nombre d'
états classiques du système d'entrée, que je vais continuer à noter par le petit n. Ça nous donnera toujours une
matrice densité, qui est souvent appelée l'état de Choi du canal. Voici comment ça fonctionne plus en détail.
Imagine d'abord qu'on a deux copies identiques du système d'entrée et qu'on considère le vecteur d'état quantique s
affiché à l'écran, qui représente ce qu'on appelle un état maximalement intriqué de cette paire de systèmes identiques. Par
exemple, si Sigma est l'alphabet binaire, alors c'est un état phi+, mais on peut penser à un état défini de façon analogue pour
n'importe quel choix de Sigma, et ce qu'on obtient est un état très intriqué, et en fait aussi intriqué que possible
pour ce choix de systèmes. Pour obtenir la représentation en matrice densité de l'état, on multiplie le vecteur d'état par sa transposée conjuguée comme d'habitude, et
voici à quoi ça ressemble. Et enfin, si on pense à la représentation de Choi du canal divisée par n, on voit que c'est l'état
qu'on obtiendrait si on appliquait le canal fi au deuxième système. Sous forme de figure, voici
à quoi ça ressemble. On a deux copies du système X dans cet état maximalement intriqué s. Le canal fi est
appliqué au deuxième système, qui est celui en haut dans le diagramme, et l'état résultant est l'état de Choi de fi. Bien sûr, on ne nommerait normalement pas
deux systèmes différents du même nom comme ça. En général, ça n'aide pas de donner le même nom à deux choses différentes. Mais ça a du sens
WEBVTT
dans ce cas, juste pour faire ce lien avec les représentations de Choi. Il y a quelques implications qu'on peut tirer immédiatement de cette façon de
regarder les représentations de Choi. L'une est que parce que l'état de Choi est une matrice densité, à supposer que fi est un
canal valide, on conclut que la représentation de Choi de fi doit être semi-définie positive. Souviens-toi que c'est
une exigence qu'on impose aux canaux qu'ils transforment toujours les matrices densité en matrices densité, et c'est
juste un cas particulier de ça. La deuxième implication est que si on prend l'état de Choi pour tout canal fi et
qu'on élimine ensuite le système de sortie Y, on doit se retrouver avec l'état complètement mixte sur le système d'entrée X. C'est
parce qu'appliquer un canal à un système et puis jeter le système résultant à la poubelle est équivalent à juste jeter le système d'origine à la
poubelle. Et si on faisait ça avec notre état maximalement intriqué, la matrice densité avec laquelle on se retrouverait serait
la matrice identité divisée par n, ou en d'autres termes l'état complètement mixte pour le système X. L'idée en termes plus
mathématiques est que la composition de n'importe quel canal avec la trace sur le système de sortie doit être égale à la trace sur le
système d'entrée, et c'est parce que les canaux doivent préserver la trace en vertu du fait qu'ils sont des applications linéaires qui
transforment toujours les matrices densité en matrices densité. Une fois qu'on a cette équation, on peut éliminer le dénominateur n
des deux côtés pour obtenir une condition légèrement plus propre. En d'autres termes, effectuer la trace partielle sur le système de sortie
de la représentation de Choi d'un canal doit nous donner la matrice identité sur le système d'entrée. Donc en résumé, les représentations de Choi
des canaux sont toujours semi-définies positives et si on trace le système de sortie, on se retrouve nécessairement
avec la matrice identité sur le système d'entrée. Il s'avère que ce ne sont pas seulement des conditions nécessaires mais
aussi suffisantes, ce qui signifie que si fi est une application linéaire arbitraire et que ces deux conditions sont toutes les deux
vraies, alors fi doit en fait être un canal valide. Et on verra pourquoi c'est le cas à la fin de la leçon.
Voyons quelques exemples, en commençant par le canal complètement déphasant. Pour calculer la représentation de Choi, c'est juste une question d'
évaluer la formule. Le canal complètement déphasant laisse |a><b| intact quand a est égal à b, et sinon la sortie
est zéro. Donc les termes dans la somme qui survivent sont ceux où a est égal à b, et le résultat est exprimé à l'
écran en notation de Dirac. On peut aussi le voir comme une matrice par blocs. Delta laisse les entrées diagonales intactes et met à zéro les
entrées hors diagonale, et donc on se retrouve avec une matrice ayant des 1 dans les coins supérieur gauche et inférieur droit avec toutes
leurs entrées étant zéro, ce qui est cohérent avec la première expression. Pour un autre exemple, considérons le canal complètement dépolarisant. De nouveau, on
peut commencer par écrire la formule et tout comme dans l'exemple précédent, on n'a pas de contribution à la somme
quand a n'est pas égal à b. Et cette fois quand a est égal à b, on obtient l'état complètement mixte, et on peut simplifier ça pour
obtenir 1/2 fois la matrice identité 2x2 tensorisée avec elle-même, ce qui est 1/2 fois la matrice identité 4x4.
On peut aussi y penser en termes de matrices par blocs et naturellement on obtient le même résultat. Et comme
dernier exemple, considérons le canal identité pour un seul qubit. C'est un exemple facile. Voici la formule et bien sûr
le canal identité ne fait rien du tout, et on peut penser au résultat comme étant deux fois la matrice densité associée à un état phi+, et c'est
cohérent avec ce qu'on s'attend à voir en pensant à l'état de Choi de ce canal. Et voici ça comme une matrice par blocs. Remarque en particulier que la représentation de Choi
du canal identité n'est pas la matrice identité, c'est cette matrice. On a maintenant vu trois façons différentes
de représenter les canaux en termes mathématiques, à savoir les représentations de Stinespring, les représentations de Krauss et les représentations de Choi.
On a aussi la définition d'un canal, qui est qu'un canal est une application linéaire qui transforme toujours
les matrices densité en matrices densité, même quand le canal est appliqué à seulement une partie d'un système composé. Une question très naturelle et très importante
à poser à ce stade est comment sait-on que toutes ces choses sont équivalentes ? Par exemple, comment sait-on que chaque
application décrite par l'une de ces représentations est en fait un canal valide, et comment sait-on qu'on ne laisse aucun canal de côté ?
Le reste de la leçon décrit comment tout ça peut être raisonné mathématiquement. Si tu es prêt à accepter l'équivalence de ces choses et que tu n'es pas intéressé par la façon dont ça peut être
raisonné, tu peux te sentir libre de sauter le reste de la vidéo. Mais personnellement, je pense que l'argument est assez
élégant et c'est un bon exemple d'un style particulier de preuve mathématique qui apparaît de temps en temps dans la théorie de l'information quantique. Je ne vais pas
passer en revue tous les détails. Certains d'entre eux, je vais les laisser pour toi ou tu peux les trouver dans le contenu écrit de cette leçon où tout est écrit en
détail. Mais j'espère présenter une image raisonnablement claire de comment tout ça fonctionne. Ce qu'on veut faire c'est prouver
l'équivalence d'une collection d'énoncés, et la façon de faire ça est de mettre en place un cycle d'implications. En particulier, on va commencer
par la définition d'un canal, c'est-à-dire une application linéaire qui transforme toujours les matrices densité en matrices densité.
À partir de cette définition, on peut raisonner que la représentation de Choi de ce canal doit satisfaire les deux conditions qu'on a
déjà identifiées. Et en fait on a déjà fait ça. C'est ça qui a été discuté dans le contexte de l'état de Choi d'un canal. On oublie ensuite tout
ça et on travaille à partir de la représentation de Choi. Et étant donné nos deux conditions sur les représentations de Choi, on conclut qu'il doit exister une
représentation de Krauss de l'application fi. On fait ensuite une chose analogue : on oublie les représentations de Choi et on travaille
à partir d'une représentation de Krauss arbitraire. Et à partir d'elle, on peut raisonner qu'il doit exister une représentation de Stinespring pour l'application fi. Et d'ailleurs, ces
arguments seront mécaniques dans un certain sens, ce qui nous permet d'effectivement réaliser les conversions selon les flèches pour des canaux spécifiques si on veut
le faire. La dernière implication est de raisonner que si on a une représentation de Stinespring pour une application fi, alors
cette application doit en fait être un canal valide. Et de nouveau, on a déjà fait ça, cette fois dans le contexte des représentations de Stinespring.
Au total, ces quatre implications révèlent que ces quatre choses sont toutes équivalentes car tu peux commencer par n'importe laquelle d'entre elles et
suivre les implications de façon transitive pour arriver à n'importe laquelle des autres. On va commencer par la première implication,
qui est que si on a un canal fi, c'est-à-dire une application linéaire qui transforme toujours les matrices densité en matrices densité, alors il a une représentation de Choi
qui satisfait les deux conditions qu'on a identifiées plus tôt, à savoir qu'elle est semi-définie positive
et que si on trace le système de sortie on obtient l'identité sur le système d'entrée. Et comme je l'ai mentionné il y a un moment, on a
déjà couvert cette implication dans le contexte des états de Choi. En particulier, quand on divise la représentation de Choi d'un canal par n, le nombre d'
états classiques du système d'entrée, on obtient une matrice densité. Et de plus, l'état réduit du
système d'entrée X pour cet état est l'état complètement mixte, ou en d'autres termes la matrice identité divisée par n. Éliminer le dénominateur nous donne nos
deux conditions. Donc cette implication est assez rapide et facile parce qu'on l'a déjà couverte.
WEBVTT
Voyons maintenant la deuxième implication. Cette fois on commence avec la représentation de Choi d'une application qu'on
suppose satisfaire les deux exigences, et notre objectif est de trouver une représentation de Krauss pour cette application qui
satisfait l'exigence dont on a parlé plus tôt. Cette implication est assez mécanique dans un sens. On va avoir besoin d'un
peu d'algèbre linéaire et ça se résumera principalement à manipuler des matrices et des vecteurs de façon assez ingénieuse.
Ça commence par l'hypothèse que la représentation de Choi est semi-définie positive, qui est la première des deux exigences qu'on suppose être
en place. La notion de matrice semi-définie positive est fondamentalement importante en information quantique, et pas seulement dans le contexte des matrices densité.
C'est absolument critique ici ; on ne pourrait pas faire fonctionner ça sans ça. En particulier, l'hypothèse
que J(fi) est semi-définie positive nous permet de l'exprimer sous la forme montrée à l'écran pour un certain choix de
vecteurs s0 à s N moins un, et un certain choix d'entier positif n. Et laisse-moi noter explicitement que ce ne sont
pas nécessairement des vecteurs unitaires. Une façon d'obtenir une expression comme ça est à partir du théorème spectral pour les matrices
semi-définies positives, qui a été discuté dans la leçon précédente. Ici on ne voit pas de valeurs propres apparaître explicitement comme on en avait dans une
décomposition spectrale, mais souviens-toi que les valeurs propres des matrices semi-définies positives sont toujours des nombres réels non négatifs. Et garde aussi à l'esprit qu'on ne
requiert pas que ces vecteurs s0 à s N moins un soient des vecteurs unitaires. Donc ce qu'on peut faire c'est prendre les racines carrées des
valeurs propres et les multiplier dans les vecteurs propres unitaires qu'on obtient d'une décomposition spectrale pour obtenir ces
vecteurs s0 à s N moins 1. Il n'est en fait pas important pour cette preuve que ces vecteurs soient orthogonaux. On
obtient ça à partir d'une décomposition spectrale, mais on n'a pas besoin de ça ici. Et si on avait une autre expression de J(fi) comme ça qui ne venait pas du
théorème spectral, ça irait très bien. On décompose maintenant chacun de ces vecteurs comme c'est montré à l'écran, et
c'est exactement ce qu'on ferait si ces vecteurs étaient des vecteurs d'état quantiques d'une paire de systèmes XY et qu'on effectuait
une mesure en base standard sur le système X. Pour être clair, on ne mesure rien ici ; on écrit juste ces vecteurs sous cette forme, ce qui est
toujours possible. Et maintenant vient l'astuce : on définit des matrices de Krauss a0 à a n moins un en arrachant les K
A's de l'avant de ces vecteurs s0 à s N moins un, en les retournant pour qu'ils deviennent des <a| plutôt
que des |a>'s, et en les mettant à droite comme c'est montré dans l'équation à l'écran. Une façon de
penser à ça est qu'on replie essentiellement ces vecteurs pour former des matrices, de sorte que si on empilait les colonnes de AK les unes sur les autres, on
retrouverait s. Donc ces matrices ont exactement les mêmes entrées que les vecteurs correspondants, mais on a juste
réarrangé les entrées différemment pour obtenir des matrices. Mais on peut aussi penser à ces matrices de façon purement symbolique en termes de notation de Dirac
comme c'est écrit ici. Et maintenant à ce stade, il y a une question évidente : pourquoi est-ce que ça devrait fonctionner ? Eh bien, ne s'attardons pas trop sur
pourquoi ça fonctionne, vérifions juste que c'est le cas. Pour ce faire, définissons une nouvelle application, qui est l'application définie par
ces matrices où on les traite comme des matrices de Krauss. Ce qu'on peut maintenant faire c'est calculer la représentation de Choi de
cette nouvelle application et on verra qu'elle est égale à la représentation de Choi de l'application fi avec laquelle on a commencé. Et
parce que les représentations de Choi sont fidèles, ça signifie que les deux applications sont en fait égales. Je ne vais pas faire l'algèbre dans cette vidéo ;
tu peux le vérifier toi-même. C'est assez mécanique et c'est un bon exercice, et tout ce dont tu as besoin pour ça est ici
à l'écran. On n'a encore rien dit sur les deuxièmes conditions dans les deux boîtes, mais
elles s'avèrent être équivalentes et une façon d'établir ça est de vérifier l'équation affichée ici en bas de l'
écran. La lettre T ici d'ailleurs désigne la transposition de matrice, qu'on peut alternativement penser comme l'
application linéaire qui transforme |a><a|, et c'est juste quelque chose qui est nécessaire pour faire fonctionner la formule. Donc en
résumé, il y a certainement de l'algèbre nécessaire pour cette implication, mais comme je l'ai dit, c'est assez mécanique.
C'est essentiellement de la gymnastique d'indices comme certaines personnes appellent ce genre de chose. Mais si tu travailles là-dessus et que tu donnes à ton cerveau la chance de l'assimiler, tu trouveras peut-être
que tu repars avec une meilleure compréhension de comment les représentations de Choi et les représentations de Krauss se rapportent. La troisième implication nous permet
de passer d'une représentation de Krauss d'une application fi, où la condition habituelle est en place, à une représentation de Stinespring. Celle-là est assez
similaire dans l'esprit à l'implication précédente dans le sens qu'elle est mécanique et peut être vue et vérifiée en termes purement algébriques. L'
idée est en fait assez simple. Ce qu'on peut faire c'est prendre nos matrices de Krauss et former une partie d'une matrice plus grande en les empilant
les unes sur les autres comme c'est montré à l'écran. Une fois remplie, ça nous donnera la matrice unitaire U pour une
représentation de Stinespring. Les matrices unitaires doivent être des matrices carrées, donc on devra remplir autant de colonnes restantes
que nécessaire pour faire ça. Mais ça ne fera en fait aucune différence ce qu'elles sont, du moment qu'on obtient une matrice
unitaire. Si on met momentanément de côté le fait que U est unitaire et qu'on se concentre juste sur l'application linéaire définie par
la représentation de Stinespring qu'on obtient de cette matrice U, ce qu'on trouve c'est que l'application est égale à l'
application fi d'origine définie par la représentation de Krauss avec laquelle on a commencé. C'est une autre partie de la preuve que je ne vais pas couvrir dans cette vidéo. Tu peux
trouver les détails dans le contenu écrit de cette leçon, mais tu peux alternativement vouloir prendre du temps et le travailler par toi-même. Garde juste
à l'esprit comme d'habitude dans la série qu'on utilise la convention d'ordonnancement des kets pour interpréter le diagramme. Donc W et G vont
correspondre aux facteurs tensoriels du côté gauche dans les équations. Et d'ailleurs si tu le travailles,
tu trouveras que parce qu'on a |0><0| comme facteur tensoriel du côté gauche dans l'équation,
la seule partie de U qui a une quelconque pertinence est la partie donnée par les matrices de Krauss. Donc tant qu'on
remplit les colonnes de U d'une façon qui le rend unitaire, on est bons. Mais bien sûr, ça requiert que les colonnes formées par a0 à a n moins
un quand on les empile les unes sur les autres soient orthonormales. Et c'est là qu'intervient la condition qu'on impose aux représentations de Krauss.
Et en effet, elle est précisément équivalente au fait que les colonnes soient orthonormales. Les relations mathématiques pertinentes nécessaires pour tirer cette
conclusion sont montrées ici en bas de l'écran. Alors vas-y et mets en pause pour vérifier si tu le choisis, ou de nouveau
consulte le contenu écrit pour plus de détails. En bref, ce qui se passe ici dans cette implication et dans la
précédente, c'est qu'on décrit les mêmes opérations mathématiques de façons différentes mais équivalentes. Le
cœur battant de tout ça est essentiellement la multiplication matricielle. La quatrième et dernière implication établit que si on a
une représentation de Stinespring pour une application, alors cette application doit en fait être un canal valide. Et comme je l'ai indiqué
plus tôt, on a déjà couvert cette implication quand on a discuté des représentations de Stinespring. En résumé et en
WEBVTT
termes légèrement différents : l'introduction d'un système de travail initialisé est un canal valide. C'est parce que tensoriser une matrice densité fixe
avec une matrice densité donnée nous donne toujours une matrice densité, et c'est une application linéaire par bilinéarité
des produits tensoriels. Les opérations unitaires sont toujours des canaux valides comme je l'ai discuté plus tôt dans la leçon. Tracer un système est un canal valide parce que la trace
partielle est une application linéaire qui transforme toujours les matrices densité en matrices densité. Et enfin, les compositions de
canaux sont toujours des canaux, ce qui est assez simple mais mérite définitivement d'être observé en soi. Et avec les
quatre implications qu'on vient de couvrir, on a établi l'équivalence de nos trois représentations de canaux avec la
définition originale d'un canal. En particulier, on a commencé avec la définition d'un canal ; on a vu comment cette définition implique que sa représentation de Choi
satisfait nécessairement deux conditions de base. Puis on a vu comment ces conditions nous permettent de trouver une représentation de Krauss, qui à son tour
nous permet de trouver une représentation de Stinespring. Et finalement, on a vu que l'existence d'une représentation de Stinespring révèle qu'on a en
fait un canal valide. Bien sûr, il y a des détails techniques là-dedans et ce n'est pas nécessairement simple, surtout
quand tu le vois pour la première fois. Mais ce qui est intéressant et remarquable ici, c'est que ces implications sont mises en place d'une façon qui
facilite les choses autant que possible. Et en mathématiques, tu ne devrais jamais avoir honte de prendre le chemin de moindre résistance.
Par exemple, il n'est pas du tout évident que chaque canal a une représentation de Stinespring ou une représentation de Krauss.
Mais il est relativement facile de conclure que la représentation de Choi de chaque canal satisfait les deux conditions qu'on y a associées. Et ça
nous permet de suivre un chemin plus ou moins algébrique vers les deux autres représentations. Dans le même esprit, la
dernière implication d'une représentation de Stinespring vers la définition est aussi relativement simple, et ça
nous permet de conclure qu'on n'obtient que des canaux et pas d'autres applications à partir des représentations de Choi, à condition que les
conditions requises soient satisfaites. Et comme je l'ai évoqué avant, la façon dont on argumente ces implications est suffisamment mécanique pour nous permettre de convertir facilement
entre les représentations. Et si tu reviens à certains des exemples qu'on a couverts plus tôt dans la leçon, tu trouveras qu'il est en fait possible de
convertir entre les représentations, parfois assez facilement et directement. Et c'est la fin de la
leçon, qui a tout porté sur les canaux. On a parlé de ce qu'ils sont et on a regardé quelques exemples basiques. On a discuté de trois façons dont les canaux peuvent
être représentés et on a plongé dans quelques détails techniques qui établissent l'équivalence de ces représentations.
J'espère que tu te joindras à moi pour la prochaine leçon, qui porte entièrement sur les mesures dans la formulation générale de l'information quantique. À bientôt.